good morning John thank you so much for
your video on Monday it felt like there
was this whole and nerdfighteria been
asking us this question for so long and
we had left it unanswered and it felt
very if I got it wrong
felt kind of like a gap and our body of
work and it points out that often asking
questions about the questions that we
want to ask is far more useful than
answering the questions themselves so
for example interesting question about
the phrase belief in God more words that
are hard to define in that sentence than
words that are easy to define for
example God even people who go to the
same church ostensibly believe in the
same God all have different visions of
what God is in their head everyone is
always going to have a slightly
different perception of what that thing
he-she it is but at the same time it's a
very particular thing to each particular
person and then you have the word belief
interestingly the question of what the
difference between belief and knowledge
is is not just a philosophical question
it is an entire branch of philosophy
called epistemology so obviously not
something to cover in a video blog but
the longest-running definition is that
knowledge is belief that is true which
is kind of strange you get your head
around which is why there's an entire
branch of philosophy ah concerning it
when we believe something we accept that
there is a chance that it's not true but
we have faith nonetheless that it is
true like it's weird to talk about
having faith and things that you know
like I know that this water is not going
to poison me if I drink whereas if I say
that I have faith that this water will
not kill me if I drink it now I'm not so
sure I'm gonna drink it what really bugs
me about the question do you believe in
God is not that there are many more
interesting questions surrounding that
question like why do we ask it and what
does believe mean is the motivation
behind asking that question people who
have asked that question to me or to
other people I'm just curious why do you
want to know because it seems like this
was only really only two reasons to want
to know the answer to that question one
because you're not sure yourself and
you're trying to inform your opinion and
you think that I am some kind of Thor
for those people I say thank you for
thinking I'm an authority on this I am
NOT and that's going to have to be
something that you figure out on your
own in heaven he's telling you different
then they're wrong this is a question
for you to answer for yourself it's kind
of a 1.5 here which
that you want to reinforce your beliefs
and you want to feel like ah Hank he's
believes the same thing as me so now I
feel better about my beliefs well that's
not actually going to work for you you
have to feel good about your beliefs for
your own sake so basically one and 1.5
I'm not going to help you with that you
got figured out on your own and the
second reason to ask if someone is
believes in God is kind of as a shortcut
to think that you know more about that
person because of a very simple answer
which is dangerous this is a kind of
pattern recognition that we do
constantly as people we try to
categorize things and that's usually
really useful until you start dealing
with people sometimes I feel like when
someone asked me if I believe in God
it's like a blind person asking if I'm
black so that they can put me in the
right category people are constantly
searching for little things that they
can use as markers to identify how and
what people are like gay people are all
like this Christians are all like this
atheists are all like this and that is I
mean duh that's really dangerous so
that's my biggest fear it's that people
are asking because they want to inform
their opinions of me with this little
one-word answer that says so very little
about who I actually am after you've
formed a strong opinion of who I am and
understand how I live my life that's
when I'll be comfortable telling you
about my beliefs and practices which is
that I am the Satan worshiper who feeds
on the blood of newborn unicorns John I
will see you on Friday